from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between oreos in the uk and the us this
is food wars
hey everyone joe from food wars i will
not be partaking in this episode of
oreos because me and the team are busy
shooting a new season of food wars with
a new country that's right coming soon
to you it's going to be food wars us
versus
while we're working hard on that irene
of course is going to step in over there
in new york i will however stick around
for this episode and make smart eloquent
comments because that's my brand
in the uk oreos come in four serving
sizes as a lunchbox pack of two as a
standard pack of 14 has a twin pack of
28 and has an open and share pack of 36.
in the u.s classic oreos come in six
serving sizes as a two cookie snack pack
as a six cookie snack pack as a king
size 10 cookie snack pack as a classic
pack of 36 cookies as a family size pack
of 48 cookies and finally as a party
size pack of 63 cookies
the cookies themselves are supposed to
weigh the same amount in both countries
11 grams we're gonna weigh one and find
out if that's true
12.4 grams let's see we're gonna do the
scientific method we're gonna we're
gonna test the second cookie
in case there's any disparities
yeah 11.4 you know i bet it's the frost
thing
this one's 11.8 grams
yeah this one's 11.5 so the average
weight is 11.8 grams so our uk oreo
weighed 11.09 grams pretty much spots on
what they promised us the portion sizes
aren't the only thing that's different
between our oreos the us also has more
oreo size options there are the mini
oreos then the five stuff options oreo
thins classic oreo double stuff mega
stuff and then the most stuff
i didn't know the most stuff existed i
thought we ended it at double stuff we
kept going i have an idea i don't know
why they haven't done this because the
stuff is what everybody wants at least
in america oreo needs to invent just
stuff it is a sandwich cookie stuff
stuff
stuff
check it out
just stuff oreos
[Music]
perfect that's all i want whereas our
options are minis
thins
classic or double cream for some reason
we call them double cream over here not
double stuff
how much stuff are we actually getting
let's dissect a classic oreo
2.52 grams we're committing to 3.2 grams
is it double stuff oreo actually giving
you double the stuff let's find out
oh look at that precision
oh there's three point two so this if
there's a six i came to six point one
three for us oh they got a little bit
more that never happens
so in the uk double cream oreos actually
give you 143 more filling than the
classic oreo while a us double stuff has
87.5
more stuff than a classic oreo i want to
know how much the most stuff weighs
oh wow
this is excessive so the most stuff
weighs 11.2 grams which is a 250
increase from the classic it's very
stable
[Music]
i'm gonna diy my own giant oreo i don't
know if it's gonna fit in my mouth but
harry makes the world's largest oreo
asmr 11.
it is
about three inches ish it's falling
apart much like me you know what has to
happen now i mean come on had to happen
had to happen harry this had to happen
there we go
[Music]
good you need the biscuit rick
yeah i can i think i can see maybe uh
maybe all that stuffing at once is not a
good idea
here are all of the uk oreo products
that you won't find in the us here are
all the oreo products in the u.s you
won't find in the uk oreo lends its
brand name to a lot of products so we're
going to split this into sections
starting with the cookies that's nothing
compared to us we have 20 exclusive oreo
cookie flavors in the us we have two
exclusive classic oreos in the uk
starting with these ones which are
strawberry cheesecake i can't figure out
it's really good
then we have this one which is a
chocolate brownie batter flavor
the flavor of the chocolate filling kind
of gets lost in just the chocolate
cookie flavor peanut butter flavor cream
creme i do think some people put peanut
butter on their oreos maybe that's where
this came from the mega stuff because
double stuff was simply not enough for
us
like honestly though i can appreciate
this because i always want more of the
frost thing but this is kind of
ridiculous isn't it they have
gluten gluten-free oreos
lemon flavored cream oreos
this seems like a golden oreo with
lemon filling
it has the oreo structure but it's like
a whole completely different flavor
profile so it tastes really good
oreos are too popular in this country we
don't need this many flavors as we move
through this section you're going to
notice a bit of a cadbury theme because
cadbury and oreo seem to have partnered
up on quite a few products the first one
we have here is a cadbury coated oreo
now these are just basic oreos but then
covered in cadbury chocolate which as we
all know is much better than american
chocolate
i'm so good but so bad for you then
after that we have these little bags of
oreo crunchy bites these come as either
classic
or as dipped versions i'm not really
sure how they differ from just classic
mini oreos so i'm gonna open a bag and
find out
is that not just a mini oreo that
they've rebranded
my left hand i'm holding an oreo crunchy
bite in my right hand i'm holding a mini
oreo the only notable difference is
maybe that the mini oreo has slightly
more filling i feel like this is just an
excuse to sell you maybe even less
stuffed mini oreos at a more expensive
price point companies can't get away
with this anymore now that food wars
exists chocolate hazelnuts
this is basically like if you put
nutella in an oreo caramel coconut
i think you would like this if you like
caramel chocolate marshmallow ooh i
think this one does have something on
the biscuit that's different oh it's on
the inside i thought it would be the
outside that'd be more fun but
yeah you got the chocolate flavor but i
don't think the marshmallows really come
through is anyone even eating these
i have never seen a single person buy
any of these flavored ones so this feels
like a conspiracy we have the
java chip supposedly there will be
little chocolate chips
oh good this reminds me of like a
starbucks like java chip frappuccino
honestly dark chocolate the original is
just simply not chocolatey enough for
you
it matches the biscuit i'm actually
really excited about this one
they're olympic oreos
i'm one of those people who is like i
could have been an olympian if my
parents had just loved me enough to you
know make it my entire life and force me
to like do it you know
as if that's all it takes red white and
blue layers of cream with hopping candy
oh these layers are so uneven
it's funny
can you see this like
a while ago they had like special fourth
of july ones that had like sparklers or
something and it was wasted the same
thing with popping candy i feel like
they're kind of just reusing this oh
wait this is cool too it has the olympic
circles and the american flag the best
part about the olympics this year has
just been all the olympians on tik tok
and then also how funny it is that
everyone's like we are only patriotic
about how funny and hot they are
if any olympians are watching this i am
in fact single thank you when did food
wars become irene's dating app
she didn't say which olympians though so
like the canadian curling team's coming
after her so watch out
the next one which is still kind of a
cookie are these cadbury crunchy melts
oreo cream now these are kind of big
more traditional chocolate chip cookies
but then filled with a layer of oreo
cream also the packaging made me expect
a lot more of the oreo cream in the
middle there it's a very very thin layer
i'm really disappointed by that i was
had high hopes for these the texture of
the cookie is way off
salted caramel brownie oreos
they're really just turning every
possible dessert into an oreo at this
point but again i have never seen a
single person buy one of these if you
are someone who buys these please let me
know because i
i think it's a conspiracy at this point
oh this one also has a double layer we
have a light brown layer and a dark
brown layer oh and then there's salt on
the biscuit they really elevated this
one it's like a gourmet oreo
i actually really like the salt on the
biscuit like comes together really
nicely again this is weird carrot cake
who thought of this carrot cake's hard
to get right
tastes like ginger which is like nice
icing so i actually like these but
that's because they don't taste like the
advertised flavor
i'm doing really bad shirley i'm trying
not to cry i think i'll be alive i don't
think i don't think the oreos will kill
me actually the oreos might kill me
i can't believe this is what's gonna
take me out it's gonna be the oreo
chocolate peanut butter pie
how many variations of chocolate peanut
butter do we need i will say they are
creative right it's not like they just
like blast it with flavors and it looks
the same at least they they look fun
[Music]
i thought the oreos would make me feel
better
they made me feel worse
i was betrayed by the oreos
limited edition
s'mores graham
flavored cookies these are the
golden double stuffed oreos it's
literally non-chocolate version of a
regular oreo
i have an announcement to make golden
oreos are the best oreo that's right the
best these are the best look at me look
at me youtube commenters this is the
best oreo there is i have access to the
food insider youtube page i'll delete
your comments if you disagree with me
this is the best oreo
amazing so there's also three fudge
covered flavors classic dark chocolate
and mint there's also these oreo thin
bites in original and white fudge
so these are basically mini oreos
covered in chocolate and of course the
oreo id which are customizable oreos we
decided to decorate it with white
sprinkles and put joe's face on it since
we missed him this episode i guess you
could call them durian
that's such a good idea why don't we
have that that's such a funny like party
gift like wedding favor just a lot of
potential there and i kind of wish we
had that look it's joe
i'm in la and i
eat food and do things and i have a
podcast i don't have a podcast i am the
last human being on the planet to have a
podcast comment below what my podcast
should be and who i should have on it
sorry joe i'm going to cut your face in
half
i think i would be saying this about
people it's just a lot of sugar it's too
much sugar yeah i don't want these joe
you can have them
all right let's take a look at these
yeah these don't taste like oreos these
aren't very good sorry i taste terrible
apparently
then we have a section i'm really
excited for which is the frozen dessert
section we'll start with these which are
oreo ice creams with an oreo cookie
coating
[Music]
it's not the best ice cream i've ever
had very sweet and a bit like foamy
okay the cone is pretty good i'd say
this would maybe get better the more you
go down i think less of the ice cream on
the top and more of the cone the next
ice cream option is this one which is
the oreo ice cream with oreo biscuit
pieces in the uk we can also just get a
tub of oreo branded ice cream now ones
which i've had before and can tell from
experience are very good these ones
which are the oreo ice cream sandwiches
then we're back to the cadbury
partnership with these cadbury coated
stick sandwiches our oreo desserts in
the u.s include breyer's oreo chips ahoy
ice cream and friendly's oreo cookies
ice cream cake
see this is a good dessert combo this
makes sense you're adding the oreos to
an existing thing
wow
[Music]
ice cream cakes are always so hard to
cut
[Music]
cake and we weren't able to get these
but there's also klondike oreo ice cream
sandwiches good humor oreo ice cream
bars and good humor oreo cones then we
have a bunch of exclusive chocolate
options which are again mostly cadbury
this one is a dairy milk oreo sandwich
this one is also available in the form
of cadbury bites which is just
bite-sized pieces of their chocolate
bars then we're onto the one in the
middle which is the cadbury big taste
oreo crunch bar if milk chocolate isn't
your thing then they also have a cadbury
oreo white chocolate bar our final
chocolate bar is this one which is a
oreo milka max chocolate bar milk is
just a slightly different chocolate
brand here in the uk then we have a
couple of options for baked goods
including this oreo muffin and this oreo
donut
i mean if that counts as a filling again
a little bit underwhelming
and i ate that from the bottom like a
psychopath i don't do that all the time
this end bit looks slightly filled they
put it on the box it's supposed to look
like this
it's what you call false advertising
if you're going to go for one of these
probably go for the muffin then we have
a couple more miscellaneous products
just to round out here are our
miscellaneous oreo items we have the
ready to bake pie crust and then the
instant pudding pie filling mix which is
cookies and cream flavored so these go
together this is the no-bake oreo
dessert kit which is basically these two
items in a box the first one is this
which is a cadbury oreo hot chocolate
powder now i'm fascinated by this one
because when i was buying it on the
website it had like loads of one-star
reviews saying it tasted horrible so
obviously we now have to try it i'm
gonna use my colleague charlie's
wonderful mug which i think he got in a
charity shop which is celebrating the
marriage of a couple who we um we don't
know buki and rumi if you're watching
this i had a happy marriage four heap
teaspoons of the powder into your
boiling water which is what i have in
here and we should end up with a
delicious oreo flavored hot chocolate so
let's go
now just going to stir for about 40
minutes and then see what we end up with
protect me bouquet and woomy
wow okay
the immediate taste you get is chocolate
which you expect but then like a second
after every sip something just kind of
punches you in the face and it's not
very pleasant moving swiftly on from the
hot chocolate we have this which is an
oreo split pot yogurt yes it's
pronounced yogurt not yogurt get it
right do americans have muller corners
because i ate those all the time growing
up in the uk and this is the exact style
they've gone for basically it's like a
split pot thing where half of it is
yoghurt and then a little corner of it
is a topping of someone the idea then
being that you just crack this
and deposit all the toppings in this
really does take me back i would have
some kind of miller corner in like most
of my pack lunches when i was in primary
school
that's really tasty and the last but by
no means at least we have these which
are oreo o's now it's an oreo themed
breakfast cereal and it comes with these
chocolatey loops and then some vanilla
flavoured discs we have the oreo cereal
and these look like the uk version but
without the white puffs and then we also
have funfetti brownie mix cake mix and
frosting with oreo pieces and lastly
these are the oreos handy snacks oreo
cookie sticks and cream oh my god no
these look like you know those cheese
and cracker snack this looks like the
oreo version
oh my god oh it looks disgusting there's
like a pool of like oil or something
right there
here are all the ingredients in a
classic oreo in the uk
that makes a total of at least 18
ingredients possibly more if multiple
flavorings are used here are all the
ingredients in a classic oreo in the u.s
that comes to a total of at least 17
ingredients again dependent on the
flavorings used so uk oreo actually
contains more ingredients than the u.s
oreo the uk has a few ingredients not
found in the us take sunflower lecithin
which they use in addition to soy
lecithin some people prefer to use
sunflower lecithin as it's extracted
naturally via cold pressing whereas soy
lecithin tends to be extracted using
chemicals such as acetone like a nail
polish remover
soybeans are also more commonly
genetically modified than sunflowers and
concerns over this have also driven
people away from soy and towards
sunflower as their preferred source of
lecithin in the u.s we use high fructose
corn syrup in our oreos compared to the
uk's glucose and fructose syrup you'll
see this in a lot of american products
as it's a cheaper alternative to actual
sugar as a result of the u.s producing a
huge amount of corn and tariffs on
imported sugar there's limited evidence
to suggest that high fructose corn syrup
is worse for you than normal sugar
nations which use it tend to have higher
rates of type 2 diabetes than those that
don't what about oreos with some more
controversial ingredients like birthday
cake for example in the uk we actually
call those birthday party oreos but they
are effectively the same thing in the uk
we color the sprinkles with spirulina
extract red beet juice and turmeric
extract whereas in the u.s we color our
sprinkles with yellow five blue one red
40 and red 3. fans of food wars will
recognize yellow 5 and red 40 as two
food colorings not often seen in the uk
if they are used in the uk manufacturers
have to add a warning that they may have
an adverse effect on activity and
attention in children we we love our
artificial and potentially dangerous
food colorings over here red three is
actually one i don't think we've seen
before on food wars it's otherwise known
as erythrazine and it's a dye used to
give foods a reddish pink color it's not
commonly used in the us with
manufacturers usually opting for a red
40 instead the reason for its low
popularity is its association with
certain health effects it was partially
banned in the u.s in 1990 after research
showed that it caused cancer in rats its
use is restricted in the european union
due to the same concerns while the
european food safety authority did say
that humans weren't at quite the same
risk of tumors that rats were they still
set a limit of 0.01 milligrams per
kilogram of body weight per day for
human consumption as a result the only
food that red three can be used in in
the eu is candied cherries it's not
banned in the u.s but it is restricted
it can be added to foods but it can't be
put in cosmetics or external drugs so
you can put it in your body but not on
your body
other things to look out for in the u.s
include the carrot cake oreos which
contain caramel color according to the
state of california a byproduct of this
can cause cancer birth defects or other
reproductive harm
the uk's oreo is actually healthier in
every metric other than saturated fat
where the two are tied classic oreos
aren't too unhealthy except for the
sugar content you would only have to eat
11 us oreos to hit your entire daily
sugar allowance which is just under a
third of your daily calories what about
the least healthy oreo in each country
one in the uk it's the cadbury coated
oreo here's the nutritional information
for just one of them if you eat just
five of these you consume 98 of your
daily sugar and 55 of your daily
saturated fat and i'm pretty sure if i
started eating these i would be eating
more than five our least healthy oreo
it's the fudge covered dark chocolate
oreo five of these cookies will be 110
of your daily sugar allowance as well as
112.5 of your daily saturated fat i
don't know if i want to eat these these
are aggressive i feel like joe could
probably eat like the entire box i'll
try one
it says
i don't feel um we don't need to cover
everything with chocolate
something about this seems wrong
it also is good it's very chocolatey it
tastes oh my god the filling is
chocolate too
joe can have these joe you can eat these
irene i don't want those don't send them
over here off to l.a
there
no thanks
well the monster the monster one was 11
double steps that's like 20 that's
literally 22 cookies surely and then i
had at least three or four and i took
several bites of others so i have had at
least 30 to 40 cookies if you do the
math honestly
and then you add that i didn't eat
breakfast and then you add them in the
midst of like five mental breakdowns and
so we are in an interesting place just
gonna
roll
away
you